do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what sob ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight endgame theories video just as a
heads up I want to let you know the
winner of the new giveaway has been
selected and your name will be announced
at the end of the video about one month
ago I released a video where I listed
the top 10 reunions I wanted to see the
most but today I want to discuss some of
the deadliest reunions we could see next
season what I mean by that is if these
characters come into contact with each
other again I think a will most likely
end in bloodshed since it is last season
I made one of these videos before season
7 came out so I figured I would make one
for season 8 as well this isn't a top 10
or top 5 list so I'm not putting them in
order of importance I just wanted to go
over the reunions I believe could result
with at least one of the characters
ending up dead as we all know there are
a few characters that have a number of
different enemies therefore I want to
get them out of the way first because
there are so many different ways these
characters could die so without further
ado let's begin first let's start off
with Melisandre's reunions just off the
top of my head there are at least four
different characters that could
potentially kill her next season as of
right now
Melisandre should be on her way to
volantis why she is going to volantis is
still unknown but she did say she would
come back when she does return to
Westeros I imagine she will be running
into some of her old friends again the
last time we saw Melisandre was when she
was on Dragonstone talking to Varys as
she was watching John and Davos arrive
Melisandre kept their distance because
she knows she is not on the best terms
with either one of them even though
Melisandre brought John back to life
that doesn't erase the fact that she
sacrificed an innocent little girl who
we all knew Devas loved very much
when Davos discovered the bird stag he
had given Shireen he knew Melisandre had
to be responsible for her death I mean
Davos did witness Melisandre burning
people alive at the stake so it did not
take a rocket scientist to figure out
what
happened this led to Davos confronting
Melisandre and asking John the Punisher
for her crimes
John ordered Melisandre to leave the
north and if she had ever returned he
would ever hanged as a murderer but then
Davis jumped in and said he would kill
her himself if she ever came back I
don't know about you but Davos was
pretty damn convincing in that scene
that wasn't a threat that was a promise
now I would bet money we will see
Melisandre try to provide some type of
help against the night king after all
she has been one of the main people
warning everyone about the great other
she has been preparing for this day ever
since we met her so I'm assuming she
went to volantis to get help but this is
where it could get interesting
the battle against the night king will
most likely take place in the north
John Daenerys and the night Kings army
are about to collide with one another in
Winterfell or at least that's where I
believe John and Daenerys are heading up
the Winterfell in the night King is
heading down from eastwatch-by-the-sea
so it makes sense to me that they would
catch up with each other somewhere in
the middle of their current positions
since Winterfell is a major location and
it just happens to be the home of the
Starks who the night king has a obvious
connection with it seems logical that
the night king would target that
location now the problem is an order for
Melisandre to help against the night
King that means she will have to show
back up in the north and this is where
we could get a deadly reunion this could
also put John in another tough position
if Melisandre shows up in Winterfell Jon
should enforce his orders we all know
Davos will expect nothing less however
we also know they desperately need the
help so what do you do in this situation
do you kill Melisandre for disobeying a
direct order or do you let her slide
because she is offering to help what
would you do in that situation if you
were Jon Snow there is something else we
should consider because John and Davos
are not the only characters that have
issues with Melisandre back in the third
season we were promised to get a reunion
between Arya Stark and Melisandre at
some point
Melisandre promised so they would meet
again and we have yet to see this happen
so maybe this finally pays off next
season now what's really interesting is
all these characters should be in the
north at the same time so when an if
Melisandre shows up she could be
confronted
from enemies on all sides aurilla has
one day Melisandre dead ever since they
first met because Melisandre took
ginjury away from her in Orion new
Melisandre intended on hurting injury so
not only does John and Davos want to
kill Melisandre but so does Arya and
maybe even Ken jury I mean Gendry was
the one who was going to be sacrificed
after all so I'm sure he would have a
few choice words for Melisandre if they
ever met again and this could
potentially happen if Melisandre shows
up in Winterfell or just the north in
general Jon Davos Arya and Ken jury
should all be there by the time the
night King and or Melisandre arrives
these are four separate reunions I am
highly anticipating I'm anxious to see
what Jon or Davis would do if Melisandre
dares to step foot in the north again
and I would also like to know how REO
will react when she realizes Gendry is
still alive as of right now Arya has no
idea where ginjury is the last time she
saw him he was detained tied up and
thrown onto the back of a cart as
Melisandre had him taken away when Arya
finds out ginjury is still alive she may
no longer want to hurt Melisandre but
she also have to keep this in mind the
only reason ginjury is alive is because
Davos helped him escape it's not like
Melisandre decided to not sacrifice him
she would have killed ginjury if it
wasn't for Davos so on the other hand
even though Gendry is still alive that
doesn't mean Melisandre will
automatically get a pass from Arya and
that goes for ginger too so it should be
interesting when all these characters
meet again Melisandre could end up dead
if she reunites with any one of these
characters
alright now let's move on to Cersei
Lannister because as we all know she
also has many different enemies who
could potentially kill her when they
meet again
it's no secret Daenerys Targaryen won
Cersei off the Iron Throne and out of
King's Landing but the only problem is
Cersei does not intend on standing down
and moving aside which will eventually
lead to a deadly fight for full control
of Westeros I don't see any other way
around this
especially now that Cersei has lied
right to Jon and Danny's faces after
they offered momentary peace while they
dealt with the army of the dead not only
did she lie but she is also having Euron
bring over reinforcements from Essos to
strengthen her position as Queen of the
Seven Kingdoms
we all know how this will end
it was foreshadowed at the end of the
second season Daenerys will be left with
no choice but to attack King's Landing
and by the looks of her vision from the
house of the undying it appears like
Daenerys will use her dragons to baptize
the capital with fire in blood now I
know Danny and Cersei have only met once
but there is a very good chance the next
time they meet it ends with at least one
of them being dead
however Daenerys isn't the only one who
has beef with Cersei the Starks have
more than enough reasons to want to kill
Cersei themselves
Jon could easily be the one to set in
Cersei to death just based on everything
that has happened between these two
families and we all know if Jon passes
the sentence he will also swing the
sword himself but I don't feel like Jon
will be the one to do this I could see
at least six other characters killing
Cersei before I would pick Jon Snow in
fact both of the stark sisters have a
better reason to win Cersei dead than
Jon I mean Cersei has been on arias list
for a very long time and this is
something Aria thinks about quite often
she had plans of going to King's Landing
and killing the Queen just last season
but even though I don't think Aria will
be the one to kill her I still can't
completely disregard the potential for
it happening this could be another
deadly reunion
if aria in Cersei would happen to meet
again and the same thing goes for songs
of stark Sansa has even more of a motive
the one Circe dead because Sansa had to
put up with so much of Circe's [ __ ]
over the years Sansa has dealt with
Cersei on a personal level longer than
any of the other Starks it would be
satisfying if Sansa was able to deliver
the Justice to Cersei herself there are
so many possibilities when it comes to
all the different reunions Cersei could
have next season I am confident one of
them will end in bloodshed but as we all
know Daenerys John Sansa and Arya are
not the only ones who could potentially
kill Cersei the next time they see each
other
Cersei zone brother and former lover
Jaime could also try to kill her when
they reunite next season Cersei and
Jaime have been bumping heads for quite
some time but it finally reached its
breaking point at the end of the season
seven finale fans have been predicting
this for so many years now and it might
finally happen even though Jamie left
Cersei he still has the best chance of
getting inside the red key
without raising too much suspicion in
the books the valonqar prophecy does
State Cersei will die by the hands of
one of our little brothers but as we all
know this can be interpreted in a number
of different ways so I won't bother
getting into all of that again today to
keep it short and simple let's just say
there is still always a chance
Tyrion could kill Cersei when and if
they reunite and the same thing goes for
your own Greyjoy I mean it's no secret
we all know you're on Greyjoy cannot be
trusted either it's safe to say Cersei
has a lot of enemies so she probably
won't make it out of season eight alive
another potential deadly reunion we
could get is arguably the most popular
one throughout the fandom which is the
reunion between Sandor Clegane and
Gregor Clegane
aka cleganebowl their hatred for one
another predates everything we have seen
in the show when the Hound was still a
little pup his older brother the
mountain shoved his face into the fire
just for having one of his toys this has
left him scarred for the rest of his
life but the moment the mountain did
this to his brother it sealed his fate
The Hound let us know this during the
meeting in the dragon pit right before
the meeting begun he confronted his
brother and reminded him you know he's
coming for you you've always known this
was teased in the very first season but
it will finally pay off in the final
season the next time these two brothers
reunite at least one of them will end up
dead the next deadly reunion I want to
mention is with Theon Greyjoy and Euron
Greyjoy it was only a matter of time
before this happened
Joran is way too dangerous and reckless
he needs to be put out of his misery as
of right now you're on is allegedly
heading to Essos to pick up the golden
company for Cersei Lannister
Theon is trying to track him down to
find his sister Yara but no one knows if
Yara is actually still with Joran I
think she is most likely still one has
shipped the silence but there is always
a chance you're on had her imprisoned on
pike as he goes gallivanting across the
sea either way Theon will find his
sister dead or alive and he will have to
confront his uncle along with his fears
just like the Hound will have to do next
season when Theon catches up the Euron
and Yara I don't see this confrontation
ending without at least one of the
Greyjoy's getting killed
I believe Theon and Euron will have a
deadly reunion sometime next season and
last but certainly not least is the
reunion between Jon Snow and the night
king these two characters have met
before in fact they've had two epic
staredown so far they stared each other
down at Hart home and they stared each
other down at the frozen lake something
tells me the third time will be the
charm the next time these two meet one
of them must die no more running
let's end this the old-fashioned way now
obviously we will see the night king
destroy some things with the dragon but
I am hoping Jon gets the opportunity to
challenge him to a sword fight I want to
see what the night king is capable of
and I want to see what Jon Snow can do
when he is pushed to his limits the
night king doesn't carry that weapon on
his back for no reason now I know he did
kill the three-eyed Raven with his eye
sword but that hardly counts he struck
an old man in a tree that wasn't even
moving let's see if he can do that to
Jon Snow
someone that has a Valyrian steel sword
and years of experience with fighting
the dead now obviously I don't think Jon
will do all this by himself however I do
believe Jon will deliver the final blow
to the night king I think Daenerys will
provide the cover fire from above now
will allow Jon to get into position to
even challenge the night king in the
first place
and of course brain and Sam will play
their part too I'm assuming they will
make some kind of discovery that reveals
how the night king can die it can't just
be as simple why stabbing him or at
least I don't think so
I think it will either take a very
special weapon that we haven't seen yet
or he may need to be struck or stabbed
in a specific location on his body to
drop him for good but let me know what
you think are there any other possible
deadly reunions I did not mention in
today's video leave your thoughts or
questions down below in the comment
section now it's time to announce who
won the world of Ice and Fire book first
I just want to apologize in advance if I
mispronounce your name but the person
who was randomly selected is Jay is
shadow congratulations
just make sure you email me your address
that way I know where to ship the book
if you did not win don't worry there
will be a new giveaway announced in
about one week from today anyways I want
to thank all of you for watching the
video I really appreciate that and I
also want to thank everyone on page
Rhian for your support have a great day
I will see you all again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you